[Music]
michelle
is in memphis hi michelle welcome to the
dave ramsey show how can we help
hi john hi uncle dave what's up
i was caught i'm calling i want to let
you know first off i love you
i love your show i paid off my car my
credit card
medical debt because of you way to go
the question
yeah so the question i have today is
that my fiance and i
are getting married we're getting
married tomorrow tomorrow
yeah congratulations yes sir yes sir
i mean after this year you know we both
had
coveted 19 we recovered from it we did
premarital counseling we decided we're
just going to go ahead and get married
this year we're going to do something
big
next year with everybody else and so
while because we often want to get
started with our marriage and
getting our finances together we have
some questions as far as
how to pay off the debt or how to
combine
households so the situation is this
uh for him he has a sixty five hundred
dollar
work truck five thousand dollar personal
truck
thirty five hundred dollar credit card
three thousand in a heloc
1 000 in medical and then he owes
twelve thousand dollars on his house and
that's who is a personal loan which is
dad at zero percent
for me i have 130 000
in student loans and i have a house that
i just got two years ago that i owe 205
000 on
and if i were to sell it i think it
would sell for like 230 or 240.
and my question is that um
you're we're thinking that what i'm
going to do is probably
move where he is if i keep saying the
hour out
and then just commute back and forth i
can currently my
sisters live with me so you know i
charge them rent
but maybe have them take over the
the mortgage but i don't ultimately
should i sell the house should i
continue to rent to them but i'm not
sure for how long uh
should i rent it to somebody else good
lord
okay let's stop there's a lot going on
here there's a lot going on
okay to start with let's just um
you change your pronouns when you get
married
it's no longer his house your house it's
our house it's no longer my debt
his debt it's our debt it's no longer
his income my income it's our income
so you become french we we
okay so we what are we going to do
with the house i used to live in that my
sisters are still in
what are we going to do with this big
butt student loan
what are we going to do with this truck
and so on and um you so
if once you start kind of re looking at
it that way then it's going to help you
in other words you don't have two lists
of things after you're married you have
one list
of things and um so
where are you're planning to live in the
home that he owes his dad twelve
thousand on does he have a first
mortgage in addition to that
no no that is the first mortgage pays
that house is paid for except for a
three thousand dollar heat lock
oh okay fifteen thousand dollars all
right so
uh i think your sisters need to look for
a place to live
and you need to sell both of your
properties
okay not not like next week
but within i mean they need to be gone
and you need to have the house on the
market by spring
okay okay you can be you can be gentle
with them but
you're not in a position to be a
landlord you're too broke
135 000 worth of student loan debt
that's broke
okay so um and then you guys look at the
car
situation and you look at your debts and
we list all of
our debts after the two houses are sold
except the home
smallest to largest pay minimum payments
on everything but the little one
and attack them and work them together
in that order what
what will your household income be after
tomorrow
um our
income what will our income be tomorrow
i think 130.
oh great great well you'll be able to
plow right through this once you get
organized and focused on it together
this is going to be really exciting for
you you're going to make a lot of
progress
really fast but you're going to start
amputating some crap
out of your life i
also have i was wondering uh my mom's
gifted us 10 000 to the wedding and i
also have like seventeen thousand
dollars
in a roth ira uh towards contributions i
didn't know if it would be best to
uh withdraw that and so that after that
or just leave that there
i would leave i'd leave retirement alone
and any monies that you have other than
retirement you use to work
your baby steps hold on i'm going to
give you a wedding present we're going
to sign you up for ramsey plus for a
year
and that includes going through
financial peace university it includes
the every dollar app
and it'll give you and your new husband
the tools to work together
this idea of combining things
changes relational dynamics doesn't it
yeah because it takes the it takes the
picks the power dynamic out of it we're
in this together there's not
yours and mine there's not i've got some
more than you've got or i've got less
than you've got it's
this is ours we've got to learn to
renegotiate who we are
as one person instead of mine and yours
and there's a shame dynamic too well of
course people bring
if they bring a negative financial into
the thing they
feel ashamed right like i should i
should have to clean this up it's a mess
i made
and the other side of it is i there's a
there's a there's a power in
feeling superior well i didn't bring any
debt into this so yeah that's your stuff
man when you sign up you sign up same
team same team that's right
richer for poor in sickness and in
health
unto thee all my worldly goods
i pledge you almost never hear that part
anymore that's book of common prayer
marriage vows the old-fashioned marriage
vows
if you had heard them heard a marriage
ceremony in the 50s or 40s or 30s in
this country you
always heard that and it got truncated
and now people just write their own vows
it's like
you know i love daisies and skittles and
whatever right but
but um i love you and butterflies yes
and
gummy candy and unicorns and um so
but yeah but the uh uh but i mean that
there's a there's a commitment there's a
pledge here in sickness and health for
richer
for poorer unto thee
all my worldly goods i pledge
and that there's a combination there
there's a combining there
and it does away with it it does away
with the shame it does away with it
inserts grace it does away with the
power dynamic to use your phrase that's
a great phrase
and uh it sets you up in a completely
different way
and i stumbled into this i didn't know
it i was just making people get on a
budget together
because it's practical it was
impractical to run two checking accounts
right it was impractical to try to run
two different lives
inside one house and i was just mo from
i'm an efficiency guy right so when i
first started doing financial peace
university it's all about efficiency and
people kept going
you saved our marriage and i'm like you
went the wrong class sex classes down
the hall dude i mean
and it's like but then i started
figuring out this stuff is so
intermingled relationally that you
really cannot
separate it right